Donald Trump is at 58 support in the
Republican primary with Ron DeSantis all
the way down at 21 that's 37 percent
down which is quite astounding now we
know that DeSantis tends to do better in
these pull uh matchups when he's in a
one-on-one competition against Donald
Trump since his support doesn't get
diluted amongst these other candidates
who don't really have a chance
realistically but at least as it
pertains to this poll it doesn't seem to
have that much of an effect because in
this poll we see Donald Trump at 58 we
see DeSantis at 21 and then all the way
down at the bottom of the list we see
Mike Pence at four percent he probably
shouldn't even just bother to run at
this point I don't see what reason he
would want to get in this race for Nikki
Haley is at a pathetic one percent even
though she is officially running we have
Liz Cheney who's at three percent she
may run but my guess is that if she does
decide to run it would be as an
independent to sabotage a potential
Trump candidacy rather than to run as a
republican where she'd have no shot at
the at the primary